ukraine says it will push ahead with
efforts to export its grain despite a
russian missile attack on the port of
odessa at the weekend russia claimed it
was targeting a military vessel and arms
supplied by western countries saturday's
attack came hours after a deal was
struck between russia and ukraine to
allow the resumption of ukrainian grain
exports the deal is an attempt to
alleviate a global supply crisis dw's
nick connolly has been to southern
ukraine where he met the people trying
to get ukraine's food out to the world
ukraine is bringing in the harvest
despite months of war despite shortages
of everything from fuel to workers
here in this part of southern ukraine we
yielded down 40 on last year but that's
still millions of tons this is wheat
that half a billion people around the
world from mauritania to china are
waiting for
this is all grown for people abroad
ukraine can't and doesn't consume all
this food
but no one's buying right now the
traders might be willing to take it off
our hands for storage but we only get
paid once it goes to the customers
this year's harvest is now piling up
unsold in ukraine's granaries on top of
last year's crop which should have been
shipped in the early months of this year
just when war broke out ukraine's cash
staff farmers are asking themselves well
they'll even be able to afford to plant
next year's crop if the ports don't
reopen
giving them a chance to sell what they
have and pay for new seeds and
fertilizer
with seaports like odessa shut ukraine
is trying to redirect a flood through a
narrow stream sending crops out by truck
and river budge rather than the huge
freighters normally used the land
journey has gone from a matter of hours
to weeks as the trucks back up for miles
around waiting to unload at the
hopelessly overstretched river ports
their drivers can only guess how long
they'll be camping out for
bro
last time we were here for three weeks
when a barge does turn up
that's only 20 trucks worth of grain
and
the traffic jam continues out on the
black sea where over 100 ships wait
their turn to enter the river danube the
river ports can only handle smaller
boats meaning lots are needed all the
romanian coast guard can do is watch and
try to manage the sudden influx i have
never seen
such many ships here you are talking
about over 100 plus ships waiting to
increase the capacity of this route is
is not in the power of romanian
country because
i told you that
the main problem is the capacity of the
of the ukrainian ports this is the
problem
some of these vessels will take their
cargo direct to customers in egypt or
turkey other smaller ships stay close to
home taking their loads to romania's
main seaport at constanza where the
grain is collected before being loaded
onto bigger ships but the bottlenecks
don't end here romania is busy shipping
its own harvest and the little spare
capacity it does have is barely making a
difference
ukraine's farmers are finding to their
cost that the alternative routes out
only add up to a trickle
the government in kiev estimates exports
are still only a quarter of pre-war
levels
that's why president zielenski has been
so keen to strike a deal to reopen
odessa but many here are deeply
skeptical the peace at sea is possible
while war continues on land
there's no point opening the ports if
that means letting the russians in by
the back door
we'd rather go on as we are tightening
our belts and helping each other out
anything to avoid being occupied
michaela has good reason to be worried
in recent days top russian officials
have once again made it clear they plan
to grab yet more ukrainian territory
[Music]
let's bring in timothy milovanov he is
an economic advisor to the
administration of president zielenski
and also a former agriculture minister
and now president of the kiev school of
economics welcome to dw last week after
the deal was struck to ostensibly end
the blockade of ukrainian ports you said
this is a major win for ukraine it is
great to see
diplomacy at work during the war but the
next day you posted the attack in odessa
is a reminder to everyone who believes
that it's possible to negotiate with
russia no deal is possible are you
learning the same lesson over and over
about negotiating with russia and putin
what's new here is that the attack comes
immediately after the uh deal being
signed because usually the
playbook and i have seen it uh during my
time in the government as an adviser as
well
was to
step up violence just before the deal
and so
then when the deal is struck then they
kind of lay off for a couple of weeks
sometimes for a couple of months and
then come back so the novelty here they
attack uh immediately after the deal so
there are two um reasons for that in my
view one is it's actually a sign of uh
domestic issues that the russian
government has to demonstrate that the
deal is not too sweet for ukraine that
they will continue third time and the
other one is to increase the cost
of
shipping crane basically by scaring
cargo companies so i think yes we are
learning and the entire world is
learning that russia is not to be
trusted but unfortunately this is our
neighbor uh they're here with their
tanks and artillery and we have to
export our grain
now what does it mean to ukraine if
millions of tons of ukrainian grain is
not allowed passage through the black
sea
that's 40 of experts before the war uh
just the agriculture and we are a small
but open economy so expert is critically
important for us disa billions
tens of billions of dollars badly needed
right now in ukraine um two thirds of
all experts was going through a test
supports we have been able to increase
some of the capacities
you have just shown in the noob river
but it's still limited so
if we are able to bring a desert back to
full capacity we will be able to export
the stockpile of grain maybe in the next
four months but if we can't then
it might be lost for good and it also
will mean that our farmers will not uh
plant grain in the fall
now your farmers are of course very
concerned about this but what about the
rest of the world what does it mean for
the rest of the world
northern africa middle east
and some of the asian countries rely on
ukraine for food security uh ukraine is
is a leader one of the leaders in top
five grains
including corn sunflower
wheat and some others that basically
means food security issues and political
instability especially in northern
africa so this is bad all
around now um i know you have the ear of
president zelinski let me switch gears
now and ask you about the his recent
sacking of both the head of ukraine's
security service and his prosecutor you
have said these moves are a sign of
strength why
during the war
it's very difficult to reshuffle the
cabinet or let alone do any changes to
law enforcement
agencies because you're basically
doing 90 percent operational issues and
only 10 percent of strategy or
appointments and the fact that the
government and the president's valencia
can do uh changes and appointments
suggest that they have operational
bandwidths this is a great sign that
means they don't overwhelm they they are
not overwhelmed that's why i'm saying
it's a sign of strength okay but as the
presidents himself said they were fired
in part for allegedly treasure
treasonous acts by dozens of their
employees working against ukraine for
russia that sounds bad is the security
operators in ukraine
massively infiltrated
uh it has historically been infiltrated
now you know i don't have the numbers
but i would say it's it's uh you know
single digits maybe even less than that
but before 2014 you know even the
leaders the leadership of the security
apparatus had russian passports so you
know it's it's a sea change but um
additional factor is that during the war
time you really need different kind of
leaders and some uh people who were
the heads of the agencies or different
ministries they demonstrate they stepped
up to the challenge others you know they
work better during the peace time
tim of him milibanov adviser to
president zielinski thank you very much
for your time
thank you
the concern over global food inflation
is far from over
wheat prices jumped by three percent at
the start of the week following a
russian missile attack on the ukrainian
port of odessa the bombing occurred just
hours after kiev and moscow reached an
agreement for a ukrainian grain corridor
that would allow for some 25 million
tons of grain stuck in the country to be
exported by sea
wheat prices dropped six percent on
friday to levels not seen since before
the russian invasion
for the weekend's bombing provided a
reality check showing that getting
shipments out of ukraine may not be as
simple as once hoped
well let's discuss this further with
professor martin keim from the center
for development research at the
university of bonn thank you very much
for joining us on dw business i mean
this is a reminder that ukraine is still
at war isn't it so how much hope is
there
that these grain exports can resume as
normal at some time in the near future
well i think back to normal we are far
away from that
the missile attacks
showed that
trust in president putin and the
international agreement
is
shaky and definitely not given but
there's certainly hope that
at least the first ships may resume
exporting grain perhaps in a couple of
weeks there are a couple of steps that
need to be taken
mines have to be removed the grain has
to be brought to the ports
ships have to be made available
international cargo companies have to be
willing to send their ships for these
exports this is also an insurance
question so
um we are still um relatively far away
from getting back to normal and and
there's hope at least perhaps that first
exports could start in in a few weeks
meanwhile it's been somewhat what five
months since the invasion and since
normal wheat exports were able to take
place what have countries been doing
to change how they get hold of their
grain in the meantime
well i mean those countries that are
particularly dependent on exports from
ukraine have obviously been looking for
other sources for other exporters but
that's difficult i mean the market is
tight and we have seen that uh prices
were at record highs and that means
there isn't just enough rain that could
be exported to replace what's missing
from ukraine
and that means some countries guard
shipments from a few other regions but
all were suffering from the extremely
high prices and this means that hunger
has been going up especially in poorer
population segments of africa and asia
and we do know that uh hunger today
is much larger than uh it used to be um
before uh the start of the war
now that they've seen that you know that
it's not necessarily reliable to just be
getting your grain largely from from
ukraine does that mean that countries
are changing how they in the long term
get their grain and that actually
ukrainians
exports will never be what they once
were
well i think the um
they could
go back to what they were uh if russia
really allows that to happen uh but
uh because global demand glow is is
increasing and we have scarcities we
have uh harvest shortfalls due to
climate change and we are living on the
world with finite resources it's a small
planet and that means um ukraine uh with
the land and the water that it has
you know top conditions for agriculture
production uh will certainly be needed
uh and that's what we uh hope to uh get
uh
in a key exporter in the long term then
okay martin kaine which is run out of
time but thank you very much for joining
us
yes well thank you
now while russia has been blockading
black seaports ukraine and its
neighbours have been seeking alternative
routes for the country's crucial food
exports
grain stuck at a silo near turnip hill
in ukraine
it should be long gone but it's still
here
the black sea is blocked amid the war
with ukraine so the wheat cannot be
transported
the manager of the storage facility
measures the humidity frequently because
grain stored for a long time molds
quickly
we still have 6 000 tons of grain stored
here
where are we supposed to put the wheat
when the next harvest starts
it's scary any amount of grain could be
left on the field
the farmer tried to empty his silo for
the next harvest sending a truck to
neighboring poland but the driver was on
the road for 14 days and the
transportation was extremely expensive
there are long traffic jams on both
sides of the border between poland and
ukraine drivers often wait up to seven
days
they're just too few lanes for the
vehicles and that's why we always have
this problem we've been here for two
days and that's nothing
but rail transportation is also
challenging grain needs to be reloaded
from ukrainian wagons to polish ones
because the two countries trains run on
different sized tracks
another problem the polish transfer
stations are old and ill-equipped so
they cannot handle the huge volumes of
precious bread wheat needed in africa
and the large amounts of corn rapeseed
and soy scrap headed for the eu
we're working 24 hours non-stop
there's just not enough wagons and
workers to reload even more goods from
ukraine
despite this the farmers are able to
transport around 1.5 million tons of
grain to ports in the eu every month but
it's extremely expensive
and in the end it means that ukrainian
farmers are barely benefiting from the
high prices on the global market
with full storage facilities and a
desperate need for grain around the
world these farmers are hoping ukrainian
ports on the black sea will soon be
reopened